Neal Browne with Bill Decker and Awful Deals. What is that?
Awful Deals is a site that I created,...
...really so that people could post and complain and learn from awful business deals that they've seen.
What kind of things are they gonna see on this?
They're gonna see bad customer service.
They're gonna see awful customer service, if I could rather say.
They're gonna see awful merchandise for sale.
We have an awful newsletter.
If you contact us, we may not contact you because we're in an awful mood.
We're gonna see all kinds of awful offerings, awful investments, awful sales, awful business pitches.
And hopefully, beyond the laughter, someone can actually read these things and learn from them and say,...
..."Maybe I won't repeat that mistake."
So, it's not for rent, but for rant?
It's not for rent, but for rant and rant is on it.
That's your joke, I stole that. I couldn't.
And you can buy Awful merchandise.
There's Awful coffee cups and Awful underwear, and Awful t-shirts.
So, this is somebody who's in a bad mood,...
...they may wanna get in a better mood, so they go read the Awful site.
Exactly, and I thought it would be the perfect gag gift.
Imagine you go to the office and then say, "Here. Here's your Awful Deals coffee mug."...
...or "Here's your Awful Deals t-shirt."
That could be funny.
If you have no sense of humor, then it's an awful customer. We don't want them.
That's right and don't visit the Awful site.
awfuldeals.com